Speaker 1: Hey, this you have to see one
of the hosts of the Conspiracy Right Wing
Disinformation Network, Oann One America News.
Her name is Allison Steinberg. She has started
to desperately plead with liberals to help save
OJ. And why do they need to be saved? Well,
because one America News is now getting dumped.
Massive dumps by Verizon, which is the only major
carrier it had left. We covered when DirecTV
dropped Oann. I believe we covered when AT&T
dropped Oann. Yes. The AT&T spinoff decided not to
renew its contract with Oann owned, sued. And now
Verizon says we are dropping Oann as well. So here
is Allison Steinberg pleading and saying, hey,
we need to come together on this. We need
that. We need liberals to help save us.
Speaker 2: But it is absolutely crucial
that for once we defy the powers that be,
that we all come together, set aside our
differences and a unified effort so that we can
recognize the horrifying danger that lies ahead.
If you're watching this and you're laughing and
scoffing because you think that you're immune
to what's coming, you just wait. Enjoy your
freedoms while you still got them. But for anyone
that's with me and is. Willing to contribute to
fighting this beast. Here is what you need to.
Speaker 1: Do, right? If you're ready to send
money, folks, now. Shit, this is a horrible
person. And this is not about just defending
diversity of views and media. Allison
Steinberg was gleeful when Biden got COVID.
She pushed all sorts of different conspiracy
theories. She said she was being controlled
through her Nest thermostat or something like
that. Homophobia, harassment. Anti-Mask tantrums.
She celebrated when Dr. Fauci got COVID. She
lamented that he was probably going to recover.
She referred to the COVID vaccine for
kids as poison. She said only doctors
benefit from the vaccines. She interviewed
known homophobic Antisemite Kyle Clifton
and treated it like he was a serious
person worthy of listening to his ideas.
She often would use social media to encourage the
harassment of specific people. She called those
who work at Disney pedophiles, get the hell out
of here, Alison. This is called the free market.
I support a diversity of ideas and I support the
reality that businesses can decide who they want
to be in business with. And if Verizon says
it's not good for our business to have oann
on our platform, then that is their decision
to make. And normally people like Allison
Steinberg are defending it, not decrying it.
So, no, Alison, I'm not going to donate to Oann
so that you can stay on the air and target people
and bully people and spread disinformation. If
there is a if there is a demand, I guess I would
say for that. I'm sure that you can resurface on
YouTube or your own website or whatever. They may
even be banned from YouTube. I don't remember now,
but this is called the free market of ideas
and it's supply and demand. And it seems
like the demand for her nonsense is not as
high as maybe she would like to believe.